how do you feel about the way President
Biden and our Administration is handling
the situation with Russia specifically
when it comes down to you know how we're
how we're handling the relationship with
Putin in this case where the approach
we're taken the average person that
doesn't follow politics doesn't read
Wall Street Journal doesn't watch CNN or
Fox News or any of that stuff to them
the average person that's having
watching football on Sunday and the
topic of Putin comes up they they throw
him in the category of dictators and
people in the past that have done a lot
of harm to a lot of people but you know
some people are split and in saying look
this guy is his priorities Russia he
never wanted to go into World War III
his main thing is the history of Ukraine
it was part of Russia whoever negotiated
before he wasn't a part of it he's a
true loyalist to what USSR once was and
he just wants his land back and he wants
everybody in the world to stay out of it
and NATO stop you know trying to recruit
Ukraine back to him why are you doing
that I told you that's the one thing I
don't want you to do so from your Optics
how would you uh how would you view how
President Biden's been handling it and
what Putin's uh motivation is behind
this whole situation that we're in right
now
well I'm sorry to say part of your
question I would argue is reflecting the
success of Russian propaganda
Ukraine is an independent sovereign
country Russia has agreed that for
decades that Ukraine is an independent
sovereign country
um and under the United Nations Charter
countries are not allowed to just invade
their neighbors and seize chunks of
their land that was the fundamental
thing that the United Nations was
established to prevent and now we have a
founding member of the United Nations
with a veto on the security Council
waging aggressive war on its neighbor
Sue uh I do think overall I would give
the Biden Administration quite high
ratings they have uh used uh selective
uh release of U.S intelligence to uh
warn the world of what Russia was about
to do and make it more difficult for
various Russian disinformation campaigns
to succeed because the world was warned
ahead of time that they were going to
happen they have
um sort of increased over time the
supplies to Ukraine and the kinds of
weapons we've been willing to offer
Ukraine and manage to avoid escalation
with Russia I think that we are going to
end up in a big debate
between people who say you know what
Putin has done is just evil we've got to
push back we've got to hold him
accountable and people who say whoa he's
got thousands of new nuclear weapons
it's dangerous to be in a situation
where we have total hatred between our
countries it's not good for us not good
for the world uh and I think there's
going to be a tension between those two
equally legitimate arguments uh over the
months to come so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]